- You've had so many great co-stars.
I love everything you're in.
So I hear you did own, though,
a life-size cut-out of
Sarah Michelle Gellar.
- Oh no, I still.
- It's going in the coffin with me.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
I'm into reduce, reuse, recycle,
and I go to estate sales like
a lot and it makes sense.
I've gotten some good things
to Kelly Wearstler couch,
a Sarah-- a best friend cut out.
And so I go to this estate sale.
And while like Sarah's busy
living her movie star life
in the Palisades. Working hard, kids.
I am in Van Nuys
(Kelly laughing)
collecting her
from someone that went away to college
in the 90's and 2000.
And I brought her home scared the--
and my nickname for her is "Scare-ah"
'cause I've always just called her that
cause she's so by the rules,
like, you know, "Do this!"
And so I'd always call her Scare-ah.
Scare-ah Michelle Gellar.
And now I have this cut-out.
It lived in Arthur's room for awhile,
but he'd fall asleep early
and I'd put it by the couch
so he'd wake up and she's right there.
I mean, it was really so many times a day,
(scared gasp)
Sarah. But it's so good.
- Here's where we're very similar.
I had a cut-out.
It was given to me, both were given to me.
One was Ellen. This was years ago.
And then one was, I think
it was Ellen who gave it,
and then I got a Meryl Streep one,
cause I'm a huge Meryl Streep
fan, they gave it to me.
But here's the thing,
- Where did you have them?
- I had it in my house.
Well, I had to get rid of them
because it scared the
(bleep) out of everyone.
- Because they're just a
little bit bigger than people
where they look like a
goblin. Like it's dark--
- People would come to my
house and it's be dark.
And it'd be like.
Everyone would get scared.
And my kids started getting scared
like a little bit at night,
'cause it's just like this big figure,
but I did have to get
rid of them eventually.
But Ellen and Meryl Streep
- No, it's useful in COVID.
- Lived with me for a minute
- I would take those in a second,
but Scare-ah is the best
and in COVID it was perfect.
'Cause sometimes people would come in
and they wouldn't come in.
She hasn't seen it in person,
but I'd bring the coat,
I'd bring it out and I'd
be like Amanda Kloots
like, "Okay, take a picture with Sarah!"
And we would.
(Kelly and the audience laugh)
We'd have our masks on
taking pictures with Sarah.
And she's now in my office.
And if I do zooms and I
know I have to stay on track
- Please say you put her--
- 'cause I'm so distracted
- I do. She gives me
that knowing look, like.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
And so I know not to say
things like, "Oh my god, I look so amazing
after my breast implants."
Like just ridiculous stuff I said.
(Kelly laughing and
scattered audience clapping)
"Like you should've seen me before!"
And she's like.
So I wish I had it right here
so I didn't say that
- I like the unfiltered.
It's amazing, it's amazing.
- I am a jokester.